am I actually remembering it or am I
constructing it
and I actually remember it
and I actually remembered
but I can see the windows when I see the
windows and I can see the windows and
I'd see the windows
[Music]
have taken place
when I first saw Pamela when I was
really struck by was this kind of
holistic way in which she approached
technology Electronics
and it was similar to the way she
approached her voice in fact they bleed
into each other in really interesting
ways and you can't have one without the
other
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
[Music]
I teach a digital instrument design
class where we learn to create digital
musical instruments so basically we're
working with sensors and
microcontrollers and Pamela has been
doing exactly that
[Music]
she came in and did her demonstration we
talked about her sensors that she used
we talked a lot about her gestures her
approach to mapping the instruments that
I was using just now were were that
instrument which is my voice and then I
was using several different gesture
Control Instruments to manipulate the
sound sometimes just to play sampled
sounds
our students are very well educated
around the implications of systems and
how to implement things and to be able
to get into a discussion around the
artistic implications of those kinds of
decisions with an artist from the who's
living it all the time that's invaluable
you can't get that kind of experience
really anywhere else
so these instruments just like any other
instruments have a gesture vocabulary
that you learn and it comes from playing
the instrument and how to get out of it
what you need when you're thinking about
instrument design does this instrument
give the user of the instrument room to
be expressive with the instrument
[Music]
we're involved in technology here every
day
but really like what is it for
and when you're talking about something
like music or the Arts I think it really
is about helping people Express
themselves to make human experiences
that are interesting
the focus always needs to be on how does
this connect to people
[Music]
these tools machines instruments
whatever we're calling them I like to
see those as something that we express
ourselves through them rather than
trying to train them so that they can
take over the expression
foreign
technology is much more integrated and
seen as a Continuum and not as these
like separate things I always feel like
sometimes with like electronic music
that it can be so hard to like really
feel like the audience is always
included yeah what's happening like
Pamela and I share conceptual ideas
about having that grounding and our
voices being the center of material I
think there's a connection between how I
feel about our voices and hearts about
ourselves it is the only instrument that
really has that sort of embodied major
living with inside us and I think
technology for me is kind of situated in
like really like emphasizing that sense
of embodied control I immediately
started thinking what about a larger and
on a stand and so you're standing up and
now it's you're standing there you're
with your audience and when you're
manipulating it it's right in front of
you and they see you
you know manipulating it as opposed to
it's a small thing on your table and
it's down and you're here and you're at
the computer and you're you know it's
almost like the difference between
gesturing at someone or pointing at
someone versus putting your hand on
their face and stroking their cheek the
assignment that I gave to Evan's class
was that they all go out and record a
found sound
s that were not necessarily intended by
the original maker of that sound to be
used in art
and take that sound and make a very
short composition out of it
it really expands
my definition
was before I thought it was just
instruments and vocal part and things
like that but now like as I go about my
daily life sometimes I'll hear a sound
and I'll just like record it wow there
was this great moment where the voices
that got really dense suddenly we maybe
were let into some place or something it
was a nice moment
now look at that
when somebody who's out there in the
world doing the things that you admire
comes and spends time with you and pays
attention to you and tells you
oh yeah what you're doing is interesting
too and what you're doing relates to
what I'm doing those are the moments you
remember as a student
[Music]
did you pack your own this
is
[Music]
a person
is
[Music]
a person
foreign